it's Pro Football Talk Oh God really
yeah who's that whose heads are we
actually taking there am I taking
Abraham Lincoln's head or my I think
yeah you took Lincoln and this is I
don't know who the second one is now is
it Jefferson yes its Jefferson Thomas
Jefferson am I wrong with that I think
I'm pretty correct there
how did Teddy Roosevelt finagle his way
into that I think wasn't he the guy that
like invented this idea I guess if
you're if you're the one who
Commission's our Mount Rushmore you get
a spot on her right Mount Rushmore all
right so we decided to have some fun
here unrelated to Mount Rushmore because
that's always the knee jerk for best
this for best that we did that years ago
on the afternoon show on NBCSN but what
we're trying here and try is the key
word we're going to match an NFL head
coach or quarterback current not
all-time I lobbied for all time I was
shot down yeah with we're gonna match a
presidential administration with a head
coach a quarterback and I have no idea
how we're gonna execute this stats are
you gonna tee us up and we're gonna go
from there no I think you can just read
the name that's all I'd be doing all
right all right then that's what I'll do
thank you stats let's begin with joy
because this was I spent a lot of time
last night just staring at the page then
how in the hell am I gonna do this so
Chris you get to go first
Oh George Washington Oh name a
quarterback or coach currently not
all-time okay yes currently and I didn't
use just quarterback or coach I went off
a little bit on this one okay
yes I did I sent you my answers to this
and you had no you had nothing to argue
against stats IR I already sent you who
I was going to pick for George
Washington these are like 12 versions
either way deal with it okay this is not
gonna ruin the show George are you
watching someone who has wooden teeth is
that hair is that where you're going JJ
Watt that's George Washington that's who
that is all the way he is the first
President of the United States have you
seen George Washington let's get in the
history books
he wasn't George Washington wasn't
jacked but yes he was for that time oh
he's out like this with his wig on he's
usually got big he looks like he could
like he might be able to do 225
I've like 15 shirts that when did he
wear shirts that were two sizes too
small they used to tell him hey you know
the button-up it's really it's getting
close but he continued to button up and
he liked the top button button to just
say you know my way JJ Watt I mean he's
not overly political but yet he can lead
the battle you know lead the the the
soldiers on the battlefield and be the
commander that way
he's got the jaw and the good looks I
mean come on this is Captain America
we're talking about right here JJ Watt
so yes I'm going with him as George
Washington because he's kind of on the
Battlefront but yet understands the
politics too that's why I go there well
I'd say I wanted to go all-time figure
because George Washington is an all-time
figure he's an historic figure he was
the first president he was the first of
his kind I have to go with someone now
right right and and all all roads lead
back to Patrick mahomes for me Holmes is
the first of his kind he is the first
quarterback who is completely different
from every other quarterback we have
ever seen it's hard for us to appreciate
it now cuz we are still getting our
brains around it right but to the extent
that George Washington was the first
president the first of his kind
Patrick mahomes is the first quarterback
who can throw with no feet on the ground
one foot on the ground running left
running right funny arm and he is and
we're gonna see more of them it may not
be soon but Pat mahomes is gonna be a
revolutionary figure I hadn't thought
about that until just now that's another
connection but that's the best I can do
with George Washington if you don't let
me go back to you know write historical
figures I thought about Russell Wilson
as George Washington too cuz I mean he
just you know because he could never
tell a lie well yes he's a modern he
just he is the model citizen and he is
always I mean he seems almost perfect
like JJ Watt and that's what to be
wanted the first president to be you
could have gone with JJ Watt chopping
down a cherry tree cuz I could see him
swinging that act that's what I mean
look at that's what the muscles that
George had they're very similar to JJ
that's why I went there see you're
making thank you that's I meant to go
there and I forgot cuz I'm not that
smart
okay Abraham Lincoln we go abraham
lincoln's
next what do you got I mean all right
I'm more of a like I go with the looks a
little bit too you know who I'm going
here I'm going and your luck I mean he's
just he's Honest Abe to a tee I feel
like Andrew Luck would trek through five
feet of snow all the way over here to
Connecticut to return stats five cents
that he dropped on the floor in the
Indianapolis Airport that would be
Andrew Luck he is no lies honest Abe's
oh he's always got a smile on his face
oh gosh golly gee shucks I mean I just
feel like he fits the Honest Abe
character very well I think that's
pretty good I like that I got I got two
possibilities for Abe Lincoln and I
struggled with this one too I was trying
to find obscure Abe Lincoln facts like
he was the tallest president at six foot
four so maybe I was gonna find somebody
really tall or you know he was a
self-taught lawyer although there are no
self-taught lawyers connected the NFL
I'm gonna go with with two here yeah he
had the very distinctive stovepipe hat
right right right
Bruce Arians has the very distinctive
Kangol hat so that's something any other
similarity between the two but how about
this one how about this one I'll go with
Blake bortles because he's about to get
whacked when he's not looking is the
statute of limitation expired on
probably not he should be location see
it coming I guess I guess then maybe
there we got to think of a quarterback
or some player who's about to get
whacked well you want sir cousins we get
whacked you want Kirk Cousins to be
whacked badly I think you might do it
yourself and the gaagaa definitely would
not see it coming
and a minimum he may get a horse head in
his bed all right
Teddy Roosevelt I mean this is this is
like silver platter this I mean come on
we know who this is
it's Andy Reid isn't it that's the
that's who that is
that to me is Andy Reid all that just
laughable
you know jolly old fellow ha ha ha
go on a a hunting trip is all based on
the Mustang it is but they look the same
way I mean they have the same look if we
put up that picture of a Mount Rushmore
again damn I swear that was Andy Reid we
had in between you and me there I mean
it to a tee I just feel like they have
that same you know affable personality
about them that I've seen in in you know
the history books and and then of course
I you know Night at the Museum that's
the look there he is that's Andy Reid
right look at his glasses they're just
missing his play sheet he's about to
cosplay - Patrick mom's he's right in
the middle there all right i with with
Roosevelt I went with his his favorite
saying his catchphrase speak softly and
carry a big stick and that's Bill
Belichick because he hardly speaks at
all so he never wants to speak but he
will whack you over the head every
chance he gets yours yeah yeah we were
both going fairly obvious here but and
and also the other what was the other
thing I was thinking I don't know tough
with Teddy Roosevelt although he's
regarded as the guy who say football
there's really no one out there that we
can look at and say we say football
except Patrick mahomes who's made
football more exciting yes I'm gonna try
to wedge Patrick mahomes into everyone
and apparently it seems like that what
do you what did Theodore Roosevelt save
what do you mean he What did he say he
said football because back at the turn
of the century football was ridiculously
violent and there were a lot of deaths
and serious injuries and he kind of put
pressure on the powers that be to to
make football safer that was the first
existential threat to football because
it really was killing people at the time
so yeah Teddy Roosevelt had a lot to do
with that
okay history book once in a while about
the sport you played Sims alright we got
a couple more and I don't know where
we're going with FDR I'm I don't think
you even know who FDR is how dare you
say that about me I like history a lot I
know who after you after yard I mean
you're wrong you got the wrong Roosevelt
with this one it's Belichick he's FDR I
mean he's the master he's the greatest
of all time I mean that's what FDR is
lead our country through World War two
he was kind of you knows we're not
getting involved in World War two we're
not getting involved
in World War two and then all of a
sudden Pearl Harbor had a world war two
and yeah he had a master gameplan like
he had been in the lab for superbowl
preparation for two weeks and an FDR
came through with a big-time game plan
and got it all done whether it was on
the beaches of you know France or
somewhere else but yes to me Bill
Belichick is FDR we're on to you or Jima
yes you know you know the first thing I
thought of with FDR is the New Deal
because there's been so much talk lately
about the green new deal so I thought of
the new deal with FDR and I thought of
Pete Carril saying what's your deal to
Jim Harbaugh so there's that I mean it's
deal right new deal what's your deal
also from the perspective of time on job
you know Andy Reid's been coaching a
long time too and he's gone you know
he's from 1999 onward and I know
Belichick had that little stub with
Cleveland but continuous coaching
uninterrupted Andy Reid has actually
been going longer than Belichick is just
with two different teams yeah so you
could you could Jam read into that yeah
like they they they're basically just
gonna stay in office until they kind of
are at the end of their threshold for a
living is what you're saying there these
guys are they're lifers you say you're
saying they're gonna they're gonna die
at their desk no I mean those two are
certain like Belichick codes i he could
be that way I could see him going down
like I'm what do you do I know that's
the thing people say he's gonna retire
what for retire from what it's his
lifestyle it's been his lifestyle ever
since he started breaking out tape with
his dad when he was a little kid yeah
yeah what do you want to stop I've got
you all right we got to stop after one
more this one came this is the type of
threat I've been dreading this one I
know because this is Richard Nixon old
let's make it quick yeah okay I this is
a tough one I went with Ben
Roethlisberger here okay that's who I
went with I mean I could see Ben
Roethlisberger holding this hands up
like with the two pieces I like there's
no problem with me and Tony over round
everything's good here there's there's
no problem there's no problem right I
don't know it's just the guy that you
know I don't always believe everything
that comes out of Big Ben's mouth I
guess that's why I go with Richard Nixon
there I thought you'd go with Tom Brady
because of your position on deflategate
when he said
he's not a crook and you flat-out
disbelieve him That's not me that's a
prediction of what I thought you were
gonna get his mind I mean his name went
through my mind but he's more JFK to me
than Richard Nixon so I couldn't do that
to him the tapes that from the office
cuz he recorded all the conversations he
had a very foul mouth so I thought of
Jon Gruden although really any coach
except Tony Dungy would fall under the
foul-mouthed category right and
ultimately ultimately to get back to a
guy whose name came up earlier I go with
Kirk Cousins because he needs to be
impeached or resigned so your brutal
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports